I like the yellow ballroom oh that's
cool
well it's so much easier been leaning
150 hello there reject nation I'm Greg
Alba tell them your name cuz you can
speak for yourself female empowerment go
I'm Casey spicy Casey Spivey is bad guys
you gotta check out her YouTube channel
lawn jokes blonde girls making jokes
that's right people more than just I
can't either haha comedy go check it out
as soon as you can I'm subscribed you
should subscribe to and I'm subscribed
to these guys who I just met last night
as of filming this oh my god I am such a
big fan of corger true have you heard of
corridor crew I have now now I'm gonna
subscribe so they have these two main
segments that have become super popular
they got stuntman react and VFX artist
react I'm gonna show you some and react
one that just came out to them that I
met yesterday we're like we saw what are
you reactions to her I guess that's a
weird form of approval he could
[Music]
you would not be able to walk love that
movie we're watching the daredevil water
this seems great because go to the
hallway fight expressvpn hey we work to
Devin how do you look at the end yeah
I'm Len three extraordinary he's got
flips he's got kicks Eriksson bunch of
great insight some really cool scenes
from movies oh my favorite
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah oh wow they just don't do it like
that
Wow by the way when their buildings
explode there's literally dummies on
stands in front and you can see them
very clearly I miss old school
pyrotechnics like this I want to be a
pyrotechnic extras my first thing when
it came to movies oh really
yeah I think a Power technician was like
my main drive I got close enough oh wow
I definitely watched this like on VHS
back when I was younger watching it now
like they actually doing like some
really good stunt work so much also dies
are like literally there's they're like
okay so you're gonna ride in this car
we're gonna do small pipe ramp and just
bail when you try to die
another trend that like luckily is like
just gone away is people just kind of
like doing the like there's an there's
almost like a reverse bear trap where
this this thing is it's closed like this
and when the guy steps on it it hits a
switch and opens like oh you can see
really afraid
oh yeah do you ever worry about like
your legs buckling off from under you
100% if you hit it and you're kind of
not like locked out like not with your
knee locked out but your quad completely
flexed it will just buckle your leg okay
I mean there's been cases where people
have their legs of buckled right and
they've gone up in the air so then they
would lean back on it and fire and often
it's almost like a dinosaur thing that
they don't really do anymore because
they weren't really wiping wires in this
now when we would you know a guy goes
flying down the hill or Batman throws
him across the thing you're you're gonna
use wire work to get him there and you
can wipe the wire so easily now it's
almost somehow fascinating around later
anyway I didn't know that areum's might
be a bad kind
dinosaur specialist taxes so you guys
may have seen you get little and fired
by Eric Linden you guys want to see me
launch off of an air ram through the air
maybe cliff please leave a comment down
in the comment section it's just like
the filmmaking that that was the way
they always used to do it like I'm not
like a big fan of like CG unless it's
use very subtly I mean I think when it
comes to like showcasing danger and
staying silent when you get computers
involved in that that's mission
impossible - you got it wrong greater
strength the bravery I think CG - that
is mission impossible fallout triple
flip crash into like a wall you still I
think it's important to like recognize
the reality of having a human really go
out there and put themselves on to do
that shot and CG you can really take
away from that just computer it
what is Rob means great I have never
seen this movie really what these people
kind of went through you would have a
duel you know you kind of seem like
there's some you know
click-clack and somebody gets stabbed
and they die you would just kind of get
picked apart and start to bleed to death
which makes your energy wear of pain and
if you get hit in the wrong spot like
you may not be able to use your arm or
use it properly you know he's been
struck and his sword arm so he uses his
other arm to like hold up that arm it's
just like a small detail that they did a
really great job with a tall person
that's to look at something like the
Phantom Menace you know you can pick
apart parts where they're just
completely not aiming at each other's
vital parts they're not aiming for their
head and they're kind of making nowhere
right I'm a thrust way over here off to
the side because I want your sword to
come to block it so that I can then in
turn come around and cut it your throat
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
beats in between the kind of like build
attention and the hero you've been
watching the whole time is like clearly
losing and ultimately I mean he uses
how weak whoa oh all right
this does a great job oh cool
so we actually do the stats for this
video and like 60% of the viewers who
watch these videos aren't subscribe to
the channel oh we're like 70/30 so
curious to see what they if you can tell
when this is done man this scene in
particular I think it's like perfect and
also my good buddies are the ones that
did it so like it's fantastic he goes
into the door yeah that's Charlie the
actor it closes stunt-double comes out
stunt doubles Chris Brewster it's a
fantastic way of using Texas which actor
goes behind a barrel out of door without
cutting simulant is flipping and stuff
other thing I think you did really good
was betrayed in the comics and
everything and the stunt coordinator did
an amazing job doing these poets like a
manner that made sense he flips and such
as it seemed to work within the flow of
the choreography difficult way that's
the rest of the sentence I think they do
a great job was kind of like God look
despite I didn't Rob Roy the hero is
getting tired you know he's not
superhuman per se although he is like a
highly-trained guy you know he's taken
some hits I like you Tom he's not always
making the perfect move and sometimes he
pays for it atomic goes on bills son
couple goes back into the door and then
of course the actor comes back out
finishes the scene people always wonder
if that hallway scene that we just saw
is a true water and the answer is yes
wow we did it 12 times and they ended up
using I think the tenth or eleventh one
Wow
now they definitely cut here they
definitely have cuts
that was a dissolve one another famous
there to have a water they use yeah yeah
you could tell yeah and create this
water so it is not a true water but they
worry but it looks like it on every
single staircase Charlie he plays
daredevil is a fantastic fighter he did
a ton of his own fighting
he's amazing I fought him on the rooftop
you know you gotta like gives me a push
kick and I'm like you just give it to
man this dude hits so hard the next day
I woke up and literally had a footprint
bruise on my chest
he's he's a great actor and phenomenal
fighter too this was one of the things
that hope our channels cover this member
yeah very great seer Baron Dolph reading
in the screen inspiration
so please yeah hold back all right
I'm a big fan of like the the little
pauses where they're letting tension
build they're sizing each other up or
stuff like when qui-gon sits and
meditates well what's the just character
I do that in the middle of every series
but I've lost everything doesn't make
you wonder why he didn't do that to
begin yeah did he feel like he was
losing and he decided to pull that out
though yeah it was just sick of it okay
guys new windows when a couple wine
balls yeah yeah
so the part where he trapped is like I
noticed they're using the dropped frame
technique which is a great way to add
some punch to your shots when you're
doing action movies you watch the moving
to my feet here hearing things kind of
move they say does it science Poconos
appeared here then here to here and here
to here it's an eagle movement boom
you'll notice our faintness foot jumps
twice the distance that's been moving
every other frame oh it's one frame of
acceleration and just like the tin tacks
- harder oh really
oh that's cool how do you not love this
[Laughter]
just because you know just like that
bottle thing where your bone and blocks
the bottle if you already know where
you're going and you know if that works
you know you you're just using that one
bead of it so they could have very well
shot that once and been done another
thing that stands out to mine I've
actually seen that really says how
well-designed it is is that they are I
guess a bright white background and
there's still the wets are easy to read
there's a trend in Hollywood movies
resin this scene it's way more easy to
follow
you know I never thought about that that
is great great cool hey guys welcome
back to Brand guy reacts to bad and
great brands I've got knee socks for
being here today let's just jump into it
see we got today VPN we will let
expressvpn ad play right there as you
know they have like first-class internet
privacy protection yeah oh yeah I
definitely recognize that yeah
now guys as you know without a VPN all
of your internet browsing data can be
tracked by is so huge props so you
should audition have been protecting
people out they have no female presence
they would like this world you basically
get the fastest speed than a penny
service provider and they also may be
24/7 customer service you can get help
whenever you need it
oh and they made browsers you can get a
subscription for less than seven bucks a
month with a 30 day money back all you
have to do is go to supress VPN comm /
corridor crew Nikko come on man you know
how to spell it it's right there on the
water just go to exp like doubling down
but anyway not trying to make it awkward
you guys want to see us react to any
other
[Music]
we actually look forward or a subreddit
our South Corridor there'll be a link
down the description it's a great way to
get in touch with us leader plan of
course give me a comment in this video
but just another avenue to communicate
with us also if you're interested in
getting into stunts Eric actually has
like a frequently asked questions thing
that he's put together
that's create a good otherwise you just
have really cool scenes you wanna talk
about man they know how to stay involved
Casey what did you think of corridors
crew love it right this is so fun
it's so inside I learned so much when I
watch yeah too much do like man I'm not
good enough to make it in film I'll
never be wise enough to understand and
even know what the drop what was it
called drop frame that's such a clever
thing it makes it go faster have you had
to do that before I've done it in
something when I was trying to like
throw something on the ground and make
things like shake and so I dropped a
frame when it was going down so it
seemed like it was going down with more
power roll that footage I don't even
know where that's called you got to meet
them yeah yeah they're really nice guys
uh female stunt girl those air ram
stunts things that spring you up board
yeah I like how a lot of this is
nostalgic about times when it wasn't all
CG yeah I really had to be doing this
stuff well that is pretty nuts man I
mean like it seems like you'd be super
dangerous spring board up there like
that once in a while though cuz we wipe
away wires but sometimes you can make
out the wires though yeah which is kind
of sad you guys bring back those air RAM
stunts yeah I think so too for my own
personal entertainment amusement put
your lives in danger
just so I can complain less about the
rare occasion when I happen to notice a
wire and frame I think it would be cool
to see a trend go back into real life
visual effects or whatever they're
called special effects practical
practical effects no just wrap free
[Laughter]
yeah I would love to go back into that
like Arnold in commando days with all
the big explosions and stuff yeah even
though I feel like movies are louder and
bigger than they ever have been for some
reason when I see these like old-school
80s 90s movies these big explosions it
still captures my mind more than
nowadays for somebody even though I feel
like movies are so much crazier there's
something that feels more tangible when
you're watching these real explosions
take place and you can see why that was
so badass back then how they would do
like those multiple cuts as well how it
was like what explosions show that same
explosion like three different times oh
because we really blew [ __ ] up and we
want everyone to know that we really
blew [ __ ] up
I miss those days man wow there's so
much of it that you don't appreciate it
and I love what they were talking about
like going with this Liam Neeson fight
and even with the daredevil fight I am a
big fan of stories within fights that
doesn't necessarily mean like you need a
bunch of dialogue or something but like
visual narrative with the way the heroes
are responding to the way the fights
going down I'm not a big fan of fight
scenes when they just seem like they got
[ __ ] handled the whole time it can be
cool to watch but I think part of the
joy in watching such a badass fight is
watching a dude who is going through the
ultimate endurance struggle having
overcome all these odds like with that
daredevil fight when he shows up he's
already like super injured there's
already that obstacle of that he's got a
handicap in that department and so what
he's fighting through everything and by
the time you get to the last moment cuz
he's trying to save a little girl who's
at the end of that hallway he's just
trying to get to that and ended the
holiday curse bad guy by the time he
gets there he like takes off his mask
let the girl know like hey I'm not one
of these bad guys just cuz I have a mask
on and he picks her up and takes her out
I get teary-eyed when I watch that you
know it makes me want to be that kind of
hero but you're this' I don't even tell
people to put their phones away and
stand up for somebody I'm more likely to
stand up for somebody than I am to stand
up for something that's bothering me
personally I'm more likely to be like
hey I would love to see if they've done
atomic blonde it's similar because she
is also it's more real yeah feeling
there's just something super gritty to
it she gets tired and she gets beat up
and thrown on the floor so I don't see
that with women fighting a lot well it's
just not believable the woman can't go
through that if it's a man it's very
believable agree with me no wow this is
what it's like for a man to be stood up
again now the one shot fighting in the
finale of it yeah it's not about the
stars yeah I don't think they they cut
it at all in that atomic blonde fight it
might have had a few because I've gotten
good at take those
except they're talking about I've got a
good at detecting when that is because I
remember when that season two fighting
daredevil showed up I was like okay this
looks like it's one shot but you know
definitely not with atomic blonde I
didn't recall picking up on yeah
anything like that those like cheat
angles are you like go super close in so
you could cut it really fast yeah wait a
minute
did you see it it's not to discredit it
because even with the wipes it's still
very difficult to nail those shots
because that requires such precision in
your camera angles to match the next one
to make it look like everyone shot the
work you got to do with editing it's
very it's very challenging and with
atomic blonde that is true a yes they
don't put enough women in peril fight
scenes like that I'll give you that I
didn't say they did I just say you don't
see it very often you don't see it very
often but it also has an emotional stake
of struggle if she wasn't struggling so
much that just wouldn't be as
captivating about yeah you know yeah
that's cool it's beautiful yeah yeah I
wish more women fun I think a lot of
women double for young boy is in stunts
women always double for me what do you
mean women double like why don't why are
women assigned a double because they're
smaller framed really they're smaller in
general to have an experienced stunt
person and they're probably gonna be an
adult are you gonna have a man do it or
are you gonna have someone who's more
slight to double like a child
were you a stunt double for a little boy
yeah you sure you're what you're saying
is based on any truth yeah there's
research I watched some interview with
it yeah I will find it and I will send
it to you but even like in the raid
fight this is a great movie by the way I
don't care how disturbed you are by
blood the thing with the fight though is
I did feel ultimately that the hero in
that fight eco wise well I still think
there's a beautiful fight even when he's
getting a little cut up he's
predominantly winning through most of
the fight and I feel like the especially
with a finale fight it always works best
if the hero is
losing for a whole lot of item then they
come out on top still it's an amazing
fight I love everything these guys point
out this is a fantastic channel Casey
watch more of their videos alright guys
well thanks for being here guys make
sure to subscribe to Casey's channel
blonde jokes check her out on Instagram
where she poses and for little boys do a
callback they're mine I was trying to
say this done whatever yeah and instead
I made it sound like rejects and Casey's
not a thank you hey but really good for
up this up I want to get page to the day
shout to a person named Luke Anderson
I've been giving him the same shoutout
for like a year now he has been pledged
to our patreon page I'm pretty sure his
card is just on fire
and he just hasn't realize this is you
make so much dough I've been trying to
get a hold of him so I could add on more
to his shoutouts got nothing to say so
can't you just say something to him
Casey because maybe the attention of a
woman will get Luke Anderson okay
Anderson thanks for being subscribed to
the patreon and you are awesome keep
giving money and maybe increase your
subscription what are the generic things
someone must say you could catch Casey
at The Groundlings performing Improv
Weekly